vous remercie d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt phrase lors plus d'un million de
morts un défi du commis 19 en amérique
latine et dans les caraïbes
et pendant ce temps la vaccination un
tourne au ralenti à ce que la situation
est hors de contrôle selon vous bonjour
merci pour cette invitation je crois que
ma mère était tout simplement parce que
j'étais député en fait des français de
l'étranger entre 2010 et 2017 en charge
en augmentation les français qui sont
établies sur le continent l amérique
latine et dans la caraïbe votre
reportage le monde était là on a
l'impression a le sentiment au regard
des derniers chiffres que l'amérique
latine connaît une flambée des
contaminations et le virus d'échapper à
tout contrôle
un million un million de décès vous
l'avez rappelé simplement uniquement 3 %
de la population vaccinée avec des pays
qui sont durement frappés comme le
brésil l'argentine la colombie et le
mexique
cette flambée n'est pas n'est pas une
surprise d'un vrai dire on sait depuis
le début de cette pandémie quelle donc
un virus respiratoires 17 ou six dans
des lits de la pauvreté que ce continent
qui connaît des inégalités de revenus de
fortune des inégalités extrêmement bly
violente n'était pas armé pour faire
front à 71 me des systèmes de son et
délabré des hôpitaux très vite saturé à
manque de matériel et puis aujourd'hui
la question de la vaccination
il n'y a pas de vaccin aujourd'hui au de
vaccination de masse hormis le chili cas
vacciner 50 % de sa population
donc il reste il reste ce virus qui
continuent à circuler avec des
situations extrêmement critique des
confinement qui ne peuvent pas être
réellement efficace puisque une grande
partie de la population sur le continent
latino-américain vide emplois informels
ce sont des personnes qui si elles ne
sortent pas dans la rue pour gagner de
quoi manger de quoi vivre elle
elles connaissent d'autres situations de
détresse et d'urgence et donc on a
effectivement cette gestion un peu
chaotique
dans le meilleur exemple est aujourd'hui
brésil avec jah wobble saunal son
extrême droite qui a très longtemps
minimisé les effets du virus du
coronavirus et qui par ailleurs s'est
opposé à plusieurs reprises vos
compliments décidée par les gouverneurs
des états brésiliens et donc on a une
situation qui est dramatique
l'amérique latine est en effet
aujourd'hui alors que en europe ou aux
états unis on connaît un reflux des
condamnations est aujourd'hui le
continent le plus durement frappé avec
ab common alors vous parliez justement
de gerbe à son héros le président du
brésil à quel point sa façon de
minimiser le virus peut être
responsables de l'ampleur aujourd'hui de
la pandémie on avait un cas tient il y a
eu finalement très peu d'hommes
politiques même à l'échelle planétaire à
pau mukuro moment cette pandémie
attablé en europe et en occident pour
faire vite président américain était
donald trump et on se souvient de la
gestion chaotique et les déclarations
chaotique de du président de north
america à l'époque donc les déclarations
de jérôme saunal elles sont scandaleuses
ils font aujourd'hui l'objet de
poursuites devant des tribunaux
brésiliens pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui et ces poursuites ne semble
justifier mais les raisons qui
expliquent la situation non pas d'un
seul pays du continent et notamment de
plusieurs pays sont des résultats
structurelles l'amérique latine est un
pays qui a été dans les années 90
emporté par la vague néolibérale avec le
démantèlement du système de santé public
qu'on dise exister parce que dans la
plupart des pays sont inexistants donc
avec un système hospitalier privé
démunis et vous allez aussi des
situations de très grande pauvreté je le
rappelle tout à l'heure dans mon
intervention quand vous avez une très
grande partie de la population qui vit
d'emploi informait c'est-à-dire d'emploi
qui nécessite que vous sortiez dans la
paix pour vendre
des fruits des légumes des vêtements de
la nourriture et politiques de
confinement de distanciation physique
entre les habitants de gestes barrières
sont extrêmement difficile finalement
apposé en tout cas c'est très difficile
que ces gestes là soient respectés par
une population qui a des préoccupations
de survie qui sont tout aussi urgente
plus la prévention de la contamination
sergio coronado merci à vous d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
cet ancien député des français de
l'étranger de la circonscription
amérique latine et conseiller en
communication marcia vous merci